so building on that last let's do the
full if else and then we'll also discuss
if else or else if rather sorry so let's
go ahead and we'll delete this again and
we'll rewrite this again and so now what
we want to say is like what let's
consider if else statements so again the
syntax for an if statement if and in
parenthesis the rules to this if then
the actual code of this if is in curly
braces and we want to keep our structure
decent then if you wanted to throw in an
else statement you would throw else here
and then there are no there's no rules
to announce because the else rules
already exist if this is not the case
then do this so then again curly braces
and you're going to specify stuff with
in here so let's do some work with age
and I'll also show you again with the
assignment operator of equal equals
versus equally people so let's say if
dollar sign age equal equal 99 right so
now we're using the integer value
instead of the string value echo true
we'll just like this else we'll have it
Echo falls save that throw it up on the
server refresh the page and it equals
true but as I was telling you before now
let's compare not only you know value
but datatype save that put it up on the
server and refresh the answer is false
because it is not the caves now you can
start to get quite dynamic with
if and else statements so another thing
that you can do is say you just you
don't want to have this so you could in
theory you could run another if
statement if dollar sign age and let's
turn this into an integer so we can use
some other comparisons again I'll go
over comparisons of in another tutorial
but let's just use quick greater than
sign so this is going to say if age is
greater than let's say 50 then I'm
putting our brackets what we want to do
echo it is greater than 50 so even if
this if statement is true this if
statement is still going to run so let's
save this and we'll run it and we didn't
use any breaks but we got true and then
it is greater than 50 so both of these
statements ran even though this was true
but as you remember before if we made
this the else statement and we'll just
do it is not and refresh and we didn't
do it
this always like to forget those
semicolons anyway it of it never ran the
actual it is not because it was true
it's an if-else but then the other thing
you can do is if age equals let's say we
want to do a hundred now that else will
be triggered so refresh and it says it
is not but another thing that you can do
is what is called else if an analysis if
statement is very similar to an if so
you can do else if put in your
parameters age equals let's do will do
99 just to show you a success same thing
as before and then will echo it does
indeed equal 99 close that off save it
throat ups and for the server save and
then you get it does indeed equal 99
right so it's another if statement that
before I showed you if you just had to
if statements both if statements would
indeed run even if one was true and the
other one you know was true this one
however won't run again if we are right
in the first one so as you can see will
refresh again it just says true and
never got to the next one because it's
an else if and then finally you could
have just an ending else statement down
here just like you've got because this
is really if ish statement so you can
end with else echo nothing worked
something like that right and so neither
of these will be true we'll put this up
on the server refresh the page and you
got nothing worked so naturally there's
a lot of different ways that you can use
this and kind of work with the if-else
else if logic
because the elsif is just a good way
that it will only ask that question if
the first question was not the case
whereas like an else is kind of like a
default like okay well we didn't find
anything just do this you know so anyway
keep playing around with that you're
pretty comfortable and as always thanks
for watching and until next time